Робочий день у розпалі, але, схоже, не для усіх народних депутатів.
у полудень п’ятниці сесійна зала Верховної Ради напівпорожня.
У вересні всі засідання парламенту відвідали
менше половини депутатів, причому десятеро обранців
не були на жодному зібранні. У чому причина
і яке покарання передбачене для нардепів, які прогулюють роботу?
Активісти громадського руху ЧЕСНО, який
щомісячно оприлюднює список нардепів-прогульників,
підрахували: в вересні  жодного разу не проголосували 11 депутатів.
Причому п’ятеро з них були відсутні на засіданнях із невідомих причин.
Серед рекордсменів - Євгеній Мураєв,
Костянтин Жеваго та Дмитро Ярош, які
за всю каденцію Верховної Ради взяли участь лише у 2% голосувань.
Інші шестеро перебувають під слідством,
втекли з країни або написали заяву про складання повноважень.
За даними Комітету виборців України,
найбільше депутатів-прогульників - у групі "Воля Народу",
фракції "Опозиційного блоку" та групі "Відродження".
За законом, для участі в засіданні
нардепи мають реєструватися двічі:
письмово - до зібрання і за допомогою електронної системи -
вже в залі засідань. Проте наявність реєстрацій
аж ніяк не свідчить про присутність депутата в Верховній Раді.
Адже кількість обранців на табло - це часто лише
їхні картки, які вставляють у пульти для голосування
колеги із фракції. Крім того, як зазначають
у Комітеті виборців, часто депутатів
"підстраховують" їхні помічники, які проходять
письмову реєстрацію замість них,
відповідно поспішати на робоче місце вже не обов’язково.
Серед інших причин депутатських прогулів
називають і мету, з якою людина приходить у парламент.
В Україні часто стають депутатами, щоб отримати
недоторканність, захищати бізнес та лобіювати свої інтереси,
тож стимулу ходити на засідання у таких народних обранців немає.
Також із-поміж депутатів є ті, хто хоч і потрапив до Верховної Ради,
але не мав наміру займатися політикою і далекий
від реальних обов’язків депутата.
Таких у парламенті, за даними КВУ,
близько 50 людей. Це впливові бізнесмени, відомі люди або військові.
Прогули - норма для багатьох народних депутатів,
проте дієвих важелів тиску на них нині в Україні немає,
констатують оглядачі. Навіть найзатятіших
порушників дисципліни відкликати неможливо.
Натомість їх можна позбавити частини зарплатні.
Тобто якщо депутат не був на засіданні,
то за цей день оплата йому не зараховується.
Таким чином, за даними спікера Андрія Парубія,
з червня 2016 до червня 2017 року із зарплат нардепів
вирахували понад 6 млн грн. Крім того,
за дорученням голови Верховної Ради,
з вересня 2016 року імена прогульників час від часу
публікують у газеті "Голос України", а також
не відправляють у закордонні відрядження
та не допускають до керівних посад у комітетах.
Втім, погана відвідуваність - це відповідальність
не лише депутатів, але й виборців, які делегували їх
у владу, однак рідко їх контролюють.
А втрата голосів виборців, а отже й мандата
на наступних парламентських виборах,
могла би бути стимулом для депутата
ходити на роботу і виконувати свої
оплачувані з кишені громадян обов’язки.